[Musik]
ach gott wissen sie was ich glaube bei
dieser spd glaube ich kann kaum noch
etwas ich sehe eine partei im niedergang
die sie jetzt bei 11 prozent liegt das
ist keine volkspartei mehr in meine
sorgen gilt in erster linie unsere
eigenen partei wir müssen volkspartei
bleiben und müssen vor allen dingen
dafür sorgen dass rechts von uns und
auch zu den grünen nicht zu viele
wählerinnen und wähler verloren gehen
und deswegen mache ich mir gedanken über
meine eigene partei als den kopf der spd
trotzdem halten sie den einfluss und die
person des kevin kühnert für gefährlich
na ja also ich sag mal wenn ein user
bundesvorsitzender stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender der spd wird und
jetzt auch sich selbst sozusagen als das
eigentliche zentrum der partei
stilisiert und derjenige ist der da im
hintergrund die strippen zieht dann hat
das auswirkungen auf die partei
politische landschaft in deutschland
dann hat das auswirkungen auf die
koalition und ich sage ihnen mal ganz
offen ich begleite das alles nicht mit
schadenfreude oder mit häme dass da eine
der großen ehemaligen deutschen
volksbanken so zugrunde geht dass die
jetzt praktisch in die ecke einer
sektiererischen partei sich selbst
hinein manövrieren
das hat auswirkungen auf die gesamte
partei politischen stabilität der
bundesrepublik deutschland das ist nicht
ein privatvergnügen von den kindern
etwas der stadt findet dass die
stabilisiert die politik in deutschland
und insofern ist das schon eine
bedenkenswerte vorgang der der am
wochenende stattgefunden hat und er wird
weiter folgen haben
[Musik]